hey guys Doug Walker here I'm doing a
fast review of a movie called unfriended
uh this was apparently a pretty big hit
over the weekend from what I heard and a
lot of people are talking about it's a
movie where it's all done on skype
pretty much and it's all done just
through like these little web cameras
and such and there's been some they've
tried to do this we saw one recently
called the den that wasn't good wasn't
bad
but it sort of did a lot of cheats to
like you know they take the camera
everywhere account like those found
footage movies uh but this one it's
mostly just these kids on their web
cameras just looking at a screen and
that's kind of it uh and it's
surprisingly really different and really
cleverly done and it has great
commentary and its really unique about
but before I get into the detail of it
uh let me tell you the story about
buying the tickets to it which I know it
doesn't sound that riveting but uh my
wife and I were looking for a scary
movie to see cuz she loves scary movies
it but we so rarely see actual scary
movies cuz there's so few actual good
ones out there they're scary and this
weekend there was - there is unfriended
then there's one called it follows which
has a 95 percent on Rotten Tomatoes so
we wanted to see this movie and there's
only one show time so we go we try to
get tickets but it looks like there's
only one seat there's not two even
though we pay for two it's like pick
your seats plural and there's only one
shown so we call guy over like hey we
can't use one of those movie theatres we
have to pick the seats ahead of time and
that we said there's only one seat is
there - or whatever HSS oh you don't
want to see that movie it's all about
any proceeds to just totally ruin the
film like give away what it's about
everything and we boat just guy gave him
this look like well things will probably
never see that movie and he's just like
you know oh no problem no problem like
you really thought he saved us I just
want to save you money guys it's like
look can you pay me the money I paid for
this ticket then for ruining a film for
me so um so we were missing the Showtime
for that because there was only one seat
so we saw unfriended what showing okay
that's camera second choice oh so we
picked that and like I said we were kind
of
pleasantly surprised by it it's uh it's
one of those movies where it's these I
think five kids five teenagers who are
just having a Skype chat about God knows
what at first I was like what this
unrealistic why would they just sit
around and talk and not do anything and
then I remember their teens and I'm like
yeah okay
this probably does happen um but yeah so
they're sitting around just sort of
talking chatting whatever it's mostly
done from the screen of our one main
character of our main character this
girl who was friends with this other
girl who committed suicide and it's the
one-year anniversary of course and
something is messing with their
computers there's this person in the
chat that's not revealing who he or she
is and they're trying to get rid of them
and they can't get rid of them then bugs
start happening on their computers and
things start going wrong and the glitch
starts talking to them and starts
manipulating them and it's it just sort
of gets worse and worse and worse and
eventually big shock I mean some of them
start to get axed off and so forth uh
and it just sort of progresses from
there but it's all done with so
cleverbot is that it is not that it's
all done online because like I said
that's kind of been done before a laya
so with this movie the den but with that
movie like if the person wanted to leave
the house or she want to film something
our phone or something like that they
would show it like from the phone or
from at some point like the characters
captured and like they put a camera on
her hand like it gets really Forrest and
it gets into like goofy kidnappings and
stuff like that but there's good stuff
in it too I didn't hate it uh but this
one's really smart because it is just
like the ultimate minimalist it's just
this girl's computer screen you see the
music she picks you see you know which
person she wants to listen to you see
when she music you see when she looks up
information and stuff and it's gonna
sound bizarre cuz like the acting is
fine but the best actor in the movie
really is the arrow it's the computer
arrow because you see the franticness of
her not knowing it's like it should I
write there should I not write this and
they really know how to start with
something so simple it's just a person
they don't recognize in a chat and have
it just constantly escalate and get
worse and worse because she's talking to
this person you know and then she writes
something the Box not sure she should
send it or not and then the person on
the other end responds to what she wrote
in the box even though she didn't send
it's little touches like that are so
smart um but the the great thing about
this is I don't think I'm really giving
anything away by uh by saying this is
kind of in the trailers but uh is that
all of these people all of these
characters are terrible people and kind
of the agenda that I got out of this I
thought was really friggin brilliant is
that this is very much an anti
cyberbullying movie but it's done in a
way that would actually speak to teens
um and don't get me wrong all those
videos where it shows someone that's
like looking really sad to the camera
and being like you know I was hurt I was
really offended and I don't know what
was going I it's it's a legit and it's
all real and it's like dude it is
terrible this shit goes on but I'm
thinking might say if I was a snot-nosed
idiot troll they like to go out and do
this stuff you know I'd be like oh look
a fuckin pussy well I'm gonna make fun
of them even more that this is a film
that speaks to that kind of language
that really extreme don't cry wolf a
point of view and it's done from a
horror film point of view and it's done
like really hardcore and it's gory and
it's extreme and like the deaths are
really creative and silly and
over-the-top but it's never to a point
where it quite goes it doesn't quite go
too far it still keeps the fear and the
build-up right there in the room with
them talking and it's one of those films
where it just shows like my whole
standpoint I'm like whatever people that
is cyberbully or trolls or whatever um I
sort of have these two very opposite
stand points you know one is that you
know if you're really trying to get the
respect of these idiots it's just not
worth it if you could see half these
people you know most of them are people
they have like never let their basements
you know don't have a job and ever slept
with
anybody why would you want the respect
of these people uh but then the other
angle that as well which I kind of like
even more is that it says okay look
there's going to be people out there who
are going to act like idiots but there
is a price to pay for living a life of
idiocy and that's what I like about this
film it's saying look yeah there's going
to be idiots out there and they're going
to say this kind of stuff but you have
to know there's consequences to living
like a dumbass
there's consequences to going out or you
know Kaakha Kaakha Foucault go kill
yourself or rape rape rape oh ha ha
there's consequences to that you know
you need to actually think in order to
survive it's a crazy thought um so I
like that angle more but it is it's
tougher to convey because so many people
are just like in a mindset I just I need
attention I need to go get it as fast as
I can to negative attention faster get
them than positive sadly because
positive involves work it was to do that
uh so with that said I love how these
kids they're not the typical uh sort of
nerdy geeky hackers there's only one and
that is I don't want to say like I don't
want to say like a hole in the plot or
anything but it's it's totally possible
that whatever a group of super pretty
good-looking athletic teens would have
one person who's a friend who's like
really overweight not the best-looking
curly-haired dirty a STONER a hacker a
computer geek but it's unlikely it
happens more in movies but I think in
real life but it's totally possible so
it's on the one hand I'm like this is a
little weird but you know maybe you buy
it it's fine cuz you need someone who's
a computer genius to show you can't do
this stuff um and but it shows because
this is sort of what we're discovering
to even though it's probably not as many
like there are just spoiled brats out
there again just looking for attention
and sadly the Internet's just a really
easy way to get this attention uh you
know and let out their own insecurities
or whatever uh you know without taking
responsibility for it in this film it's
saying hey if you're gonna do this shit
got to take the responsibility for it uh
but it doesn't all in them in a still
traditional horror-film manner that's
what's so wonderful about that you can
watch it and just enjoy it as a horror
film but in the back of your head you're
sort of thinking yeah maybe I should've
picked on that one kid you know just for
pretty much no reason is that go killing
yourself or something like that um so
it's because I mean we're we have seen
and we're gonna see a lot more videos
about you know the trials and the
terrible things about cyberbullying or
just bullying in general uh and trust me
when I say it's not like stop those it's
like no no they're they're very
heartbreaking and they're hard to watch
but at the same time you have to try
other avenues that can work and I think
this one to people who do try this stuff
it would probably or even on the verge
of kind of doing this stuff uh this
would probably speak a little closer cuz
it's just like a big punch in the face
for it and it's a it's a horror film uh
so with that said I'm not gonna act like
this is the big you know now
cyberbullying is gonna be gone no baby
will have no impact at all it's just
it's a clever attempt at doing this
while also telling a good scary story uh
but with that said I have a prediction
for this movie this is my guess I think
a lot of people are gonna see it and
they're gonna be like wow this was great
this was really cool and trying
different stuff and everything and
because of that there's gonna be a lot
of other people coming in like trying to
nitpick the problems with it and it's
like they hear the hype oh go ahead and
scare you come on and it's if you're
going in with that attitude you're not
gonna like it because there are you know
a lot of nitpicks with it that you can
make fun and Phrixus the main character
doesn't know what a troll is what it's
it's a lot of those things where some of
these setups are like okay you're doing
this for like the handful of people that
don't know some of these computer terms
which seems silly anyway cuz the whole
movie is done from her screen if you
don't know computer stuff you're not
gonna be able to follow all this stuff
um and then she also doesn't know how to
play I never
it's like who doesn't know a what a
troll
be how to play I never it is very
bizarre um but again they're doing it
obviously to explain to the audience
that those scenes are kind of forced um
and in terms of character I mean are you
really going in expecting like that much
like of a psychological you know dive
into when you go into a horror film you
know pretty much a slasher film where
people just get axed off one by one
not really um but they're totally
serviceable and they're decent actors I
was really amazed when this movie
started and it's just the girl talking
to her boyfriend and I'm like I feel
like I'm watching a conversation this is
really good we're like the first
paranormal activity I'm like I'm
watching two actors I'm sorry they're
trying their best to act realistic and
read this script I'm watching two actors
I think there's never for a minute where
I felt like I was watching real life uh
but these kids are pretty good once in a
while there's something that's a little
for us like I said what's a troll um but
uh but it's mostly done really well and
another kind of complaint I have is that
the build up in this movie is so great
and they always know it try calling the
police and they show how that doesn't
work we'll try looking up reporting in
they show how that doesn't work every
avenue they tried to do for the most
part they show how it can't work if
someone tries to leave it show what
happens when someone tries to leave um
because it is a supernatural you know
entity doing all this so it's like you
know what what can this thing do um but
uh but the downside of that surprisingly
for me anyway there was no actual scary
imagery the build-up in all of it was
amazing like I was laughing with joy
throughout a lot of this because I loved
these setups you know and you know
there's only there's a camera in the
corner and they don't know what it is
and then like one of the people sits up
and you see the other camera him set up
it's like oh my god there's somebody in
that room the cameras in the room you
know and you're waiting for it to pay
off and they're building it up and the
person's getting closer and closer you
can hear the audience going
like that uh but then the actual payoff
the scary imagery that they cut to if
anything is almost more funny than it is
actually scary they go more for the gore
and the creativity of the gore than the
actual scariness and that's kind of a
letdown I really wish they would go
count the Paranormal Activity route
where it's like they would show some
really actually legitimately creepy
imagery um and you can because it's a
supernatural thing going on uh but they
don't but the build-up it is so great um
Andy and the setups are so great and
this ghost talk to them has a sense of
humor too as like this really evil sense
of humor and it's all done through the
text uh and it's uh it's just it's so
much fun to see in a funny way because
all these people are such terrible
people it's all you're both kind of
afraid for them but you're also kind of
you're enjoying them see their come get
their comeuppance as well so it's a nice
mix you know they're just teens as well
and they do stupid things that teens do
but you again like a lot of famous
slasher films right the 13th and all
that stuff you know when they go and do
stupid teen stuff I mean there's
consequences to it too and this is like
the ultimate in-your-face you know
consequence it's the boy who cried wolf
um so yeah it's I really enjoy the movie
I there's definitely some problems I
have with it but they're they're not too
bad that the scene where they actually
do play them I never game goes on a bit
but the progression from each scare to
the next and the way they sort of pace
it is so nicely done and I was never
bored by it I want to see what the next
what this ghost was going to do next
because the ghost has such this
diabolical wicked way of really
torturing these people more
psychologically than gora though you do
get the gory as well um and like I said
is for something that's a big issue
right now cyberbullying and it's just
it's just so nice to see something that
just goes like so extreme and so
in-your-face and you know
or not it will have that big an impact I
mean my guess would be probably not but
it's still it's it's so great to see
it's so great to see someone that tries
sort of this avenue of you know if
people that sort of use this extreme
crazy you know in-your-face style also
combating it with this super extreme
crazy in-your-face style uh so yeah it's
with that said I don't think it's like a
phenomenal masterpiece like I said
there's no like there's not any super
gray character development or anything
like that and even the idea of serve
this online a horror film it's kind of
been done before but it's done so well
here uh and it just sort of keeps adding
twist after twist but again it's if you
look the trailer and you're like I can't
do that I can't just look at the screens
talking to each other and switching out
and windows opening up and closing and
reading text if you can't do that it's
not gonna sway you this isn't a movie
that's gonna be like it's so good it
will win you over despite that it's no
it's done very well but it is exactly
that it's looking at these screens that
freeze up and get the glitches sometimes
that adds to the scare you know sort of
the weird embedding you know like
suddenly an I will be up here when the
person is moving that'll go to normal
with the glitches and stuff but uh but
if you look at you're just like oh this
looks creative and different and new
let's try it uh it's fun it's a really
fun movie to check out and that's one of
the reasons I did the v-log is because
I'm just over anything that's trying
something new and different my big fear
is that this does turn into kind of like
a new found footage thing I don't really
want to see like twenty other films
trying this and I get the feeling that's
going to happen um but you know now
before that craze happens and before we
all start saying oh god it started with
that unfriended movie that's a piece of
shit cuz it started all this stuff it's
like no I I think it's good to
acknowledge now before that craze
happens if it does happen that this was
a fun movie it's not like a super deep
or meaningful movie but it's a good
canary tail that speaks to a certain age
in my opinion not being that age but
that try speaking to that age in a
different way and in a fun way and in a
way that you can watch it just as
entertainment or you can watch it as hey
there is a very obvious but good moral
in here as well that you know is trying
to be addressed right now and it does it
in a really fun entertaining way you
know I always say the best lessons are
learned through fun but it's through
something where it's like you want to
watch it you want to participate in it
because it's fun not because you feel
like you have to but because you want to
and that's why I really like this movie
because it's teaching a lesson you want
to learn you want to see these people
get their answers handed to him cuz they
were so mean to this girl and you want
to see them you know get backstabbed the
same way they backstab her so but at the
same time you know they're just teens
it's like hey this this could kind of
happen to you you never know your
insecurities you know and that I was a
teen tune we all had our insecurities
and let it out on the wrong people so
it's it's it's a really fun movie and I
definitely really really enjoyed it so
yeah I don't think it's for everyone but
I think it's for anyone that sees this
it's like oh that looks kind of fun it's
it's more than kind of fun it's a lot of
fun if you're willing to put up with
nothing but screens and windows closing
and opening up in a frantic air oh I'm
going it does everything that you can
with this scenario uh they even sort of
don't do much of the walking around like
holding the camera there's like at one
point when the characters gets up it
starts walking around on the camera I'm
like oh my god are we really doing this
but they don't do it for very long they
sort of get rid of it pretty quickly and
there's more to things you can predict
pretty fast I mean like there's a
character at some point like whips out a
gun like as a joke like oh yeah I have a
gut it well I wonder what's gonna happen
with that there's another one that has a
knife that's like oh well gee I wonder
what's gonna happen with that um but for
the most part I thought was pretty
clever I thought as these sort of
slasher slash supernatural movies go
this was really different and a lot of
fun and cleverly done had a good
and yeah like I said I like anything
that's even it's just a little different
or a lot different anything that just
sort of makes this is up mixes it up a
bit and does it very cleverly this is a
very clever movie so that's about all my
rambling I have if you can go check it
out go check it out
take care